russian forces hit the central square of
ukraine's second largest city on the
sixth day of war as the attack left
buildings near the local government
headquarters in ruins
residential areas have also come under
heavy shelling as russia hit
non-military targets
the news agency story full set it
corroborated and verified the location
of this footage the surveillance video
appears to show a series of explosions
outside an apartment complex in kharkiv
as several people ran for cover
[Music]
homes were destroyed and the city's
governor said on monday that at least 10
civilians were killed as continued
shelling interfered with rescue efforts
many residents concerned about the
attacks took cover in makeshift shelters
and basements
um
as the violence has escalated the united
nations said more than half a million
people have fled ukraine and the number
could rise to 4 million in the coming
weeks the scale of civilian casualties
and damage
to civilian infrastructure even in these
very early days
is alarming
russian president vladimir putin said no
strikes targeting civilians were carried
out and blamed what he called ukrainian
nationalists for attacking residential
areas according to state media
russia didn't seize any major ukrainian
cities but new satellite images showed a
nearly 40-mile long convoy moving closer
to kiev on monday as talks between
delegations from russia and ukraine on a
potential ceasefire ended with no deal
so even though both delegations appeared
to be sending positive signals and
agreed to another round of talks the man
who launched the war
seems to not yet be backing down we're
not yet sure when these next round of
talks are going to take place but what
we do know is that ukraine is showing
strong resistance and has dug into
defended cities